ah ah voilà voilà voilà comment vous
allez j'espère vous allez bien
aujourd'hui il ya du changement il ya
beaucoup de changements oui c'est la
première fois que j'utilise tout nouveau
boîtier avec le catch est en train de
filmer tout de suite c'est le sony à 7s
3 jusqu'à présent j'utilisais ça c'était
d'ailleurs toujours gh5 de panasonic est
super intéressant mais il fallait aller
plus loin notamment au niveau du suivi
du tracking de la netteté parce que ça
c'est juste ou fils inc quel que soit
son rang monde et d'un côté de l'autre à
droite à gauche tient de la netteté et
ça c'est très bien donc là suis content
d'envoyer de l'ogre est donc m'en voulez
pas si toutefois et bien
j'essaye des choses avoue toutefois tout
n'est pas parfait tout de suite eh bien
il ya des choses qui vont évoluer
regardez là j'ai changé un petit peu les
choses de place je vous mets de
l'éclairage je vous mets de la lumière à
droite à gauche de tous les côtés c'est
sympa on voit donc aujourd'hui on va
vraiment se concentrer sur autre chose
que sur ce changement de set up mais
tenez en tout cas à l'introduire
on va se parler de ça en fait on va
avoir le raid minutes 10 et les renmin
de 10 pro deux nouveaux smartphones de
chirurgie qui sont très intéressants on
va donc cela regardez regardez quelle
est la différence entre ces deux
produits on va regarder lequel est
intéressant pour vous peut-être qu'elles
sont vraiment les les points à retenir
là dessus parce que ce sont quand même
deux produits très très très similaire
en plein de points mais malgré tout ils
ont chacun leur indienne propres
donc on va regarder ça je vais tout vous
dire et je compte des matins ça vous met
dès maintenant sur vous pour me dire ce
que vous pensez de ce set up la dcri
petite lumière le 11 d'un côté le bleu
de l'autre monsieur vrai au milieu cette
nouvelle caméra dites moi ce que vous en
pensez on va en commentaire comme ça on
commence tranquillement et on y va dès
maintenant
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rhino chez
briochine vous connaissez je vous en ai
déjà beaucoup parlé il fabrique des
coques pour venir protéger votre
smartphone et protéger son smartphone
c'est extrêmement important alors vous
avez des coques temps plein d'univers
différents on va avoir aussi bien du
fortnight on va avoir de l'autoroute
heures on va se retrouver avec du fairy
tail aussi qui est aussi très très sympa
assassination classroom on a aussi des
dans le sport bien évidemment avec les
chicago bulls mais aussi les coqs qui
sont approuvés par la nasa et puis si
vous voulez quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus standard et bien vous avez des gars
très sympa un très très très court qui
sont solides et également avec un petit
effet carabobo nord il ya également
d'autres coop dans un autre univers qui
vont arriver avec notamment one piece
qui ne saurait tarder et ainsi que le
psg donc si vous êtes fan de foot et fan
de one piece voir là où l'autre ou les
deux pourquoi pas et bien vous allez
avoir de quoi vous faire plaisir et si
vous voulez voir le dos de votre
smartphone vous avez également des
crashs garde ou des mots des knicks qui
sont personnalisables
cerino chili a aussi plein d'autres
produits super intéressant comme
notamment d apax crime protector là ce
n'est pas un éventail ce sont des
impacts screen protector qui vont dire
complètement protégé la face avant de
smartphones et puis il faut savoir
également que chirino chine vous avez
aussi des accessoires notamment des
câbles il en apporte une moreau et vous
avez également plus des backplate qui
vont venir se mettre au dos de votre
crasse garde du modèle x fournir
continuer à personnaliser l'expérience
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description pour découvrir ces corps qui
vous inscrire parce qu'elles vont
arriver justement elles vont pas tarder
à arriver sur les renmin 10h30 hne 10pro
de pointe les premiers avertis vous vous
inscrivez via le lien en bas dans la
description et vous rentrez votre email
comme ça vous serez informés et surtout
vous bénéficiez de 5 % de remise sur
votre prochain achat chéri dauchy et ça
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
on a un look et y fera il praille près
similaire mais malgré tout un plat ils
sont en tout cas doutais que je l'aurais
fait je faisais pas nettoyé il regrette
où chacun leur adn un petit peu propre
là vous avez leurrer
10la vous avez le modèle professionnel
on le voit déjà une petite différence de
taille le rémy 9 10 et un poil plus
petit que le pro le prochain pas le plus
grand et vous avez une différence vous
voyez vraiment au niveau des capteurs
photo ça c'est le dis ça c'est le pro le
prochain point le plus grand parce
qu'ici vous avez un capteur 200 8
mégapixels contre 40 8 mégapixels de
l'autre côté il ya aussi une différence
de poids le rémi d'autres disent les 178
8 g balle est faute extrêmement précis
contre un modèle professionnel qui fait
193 g
dans les deux cas vous avez le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui se situe sur
la tranche et qui déverrouille vraiment
hypra il pratiquera vite dans les deux
cas ce que je vais bien aimé c'est que
vous avez un petit dos la voyez qui est
légèrement incurvé on va voir ce côté
plat sur le dessous est sur le dessus
dans les deux cas vous allez avoir un
écran donne displaced à dire un écran en
fait avec le petit trou la petite caméra
qui est planqué juste au dessus ici on
est sur un écran amoled 6,7 pousse sur
leur éminente pro et les sons de 6,43
pousse sur leurs ennemis notre 10 dans
les deux cas vous êtes en full hd 2400
par 1080 pixels
moi je trouve lumineux alors une fois
vous serez en plein soleil le soleil
derrière vous bon il ya un moment ce
n'est pas de magie mais déjà comme ça
pour aller à l'extérieur pour profiter
de la lumière des beaux jours
eh bien vous avez de quoi faire taux
d'actualisation ici qui en 60 hertz ou
ans en voyage parce que oui vous pouvais
transforme en hertz sur le modèle pro
modèle pro uniquement l'autre modèle 60
hertz voyez vous choisissez donc vous
avoir plus un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 249 donc le modèle pro il est
réellement dédié pour les gamers
donc si vous êtes gamer si vous voulez
bonne expérience de gaming là vous irez
plus en terme de performance et
bienvenue sur modèle professionnel si
maintenant vous voulez quelque chose qui
est un peu moins exigeant où vous irez
un peu moindre regret sur le reminbi 10
il ya une différence de prix je vous le
dis tout de suite le coup de la feuille
qui s'envole
chaque fois le rémi nogues 10 m en
version 4 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage et coûte moins de 200 euros ou
299 euros 90 tandis que le modèle
professionnel vous avez plusieurs
configurations déjà une version 6 giga
de ram 64 giga de stockage à 279 euros
90 une version c'est giga de ram 128 go
de stockage à 299 euros 90 et vous avez
une version 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage à 349 euros 90 me je suis pas
sûr que la version 8 soit extrêmement
intéressante durer peut-être d'autres
smartphones de configuration à venir
chercher à 350 euros en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que la version 428 sur le
modèle
10h10 normal eh bien je trouve pas mal
moins de 200 euros franchement là dessus
il n'y a rien à dire extrêmement honnête
si maintenant vous voulez aller un poil
plus loin parce que je vous conseille
ans le 6 64 toujours un petit peu
dubitatif 1,64 g part que ce soit pas
assez 128 c'est mieux pour ajouter 100
euros alors pour 100 euros de plus vous
avez effectivement un plus gros
processeur vous avez instinct dragonne
532g g power gaming tandis que sur et
modèles vous avez un stade ragone 678
c'est pas la même chose ces rencontres
pas exactement la même histoire alors le
7 132 g est intéressant par metref faire
pas mal de choses on n'ira pas aussi
loin qu'en 7 165 g dont on a beaucoup
parlé notamment l'année dernière on se
doutera question va pas être sur un
smartphone qui va faire tourner des jeux
extrêmement gourmand non c'est clair que
non non non et non
c'est évident qu'ici on n'a pas un très
gros smartphone de gaming avec des
performances complètement dingue dingue
dingue mais malgré tout ça marche bien
et ça c'est un très gros point fort ici
pas de smartphone 5g des smartphones 4g
sont rémi de 19 ans une batterie de 5000
millan perreur qui se surnommait
professionnelle assez rigolo on à
batterie de 5000 20 millions terreur ils
ont dû rajouter un petit peu dans les
deux cas vous avez de la recharge 33
watts
côté logiciel vous tourner ici sur me
wade 12 basé sur un android 11
franchement ça marche très très bien tel
claire thèmes sombres il n'y a pas de
choses très très surprenant votre schéma
de couleur quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus saturés moins saturé pour vous
pouvez les 100 automatique moi j'aime
bien le côté saturé que je trouve super
sympa et vous venez de le réchauffer un
point comme ça voyez je trouve que la
plains pas trop vers un poil plus chaud
comme ça vous avez un compromis qui est
super sympa c'est très efficace ça
marche super bien
après dans vos paramètres vous retrouver
vraiment tout ce que vous voulez c'est
plutôt bien que la céni avait douze en
tout cas moi j'aime bien c'est une très
bonne expérience logiciel vous avez
choix d'activer ou non votre tiroir
d'applications moi je les activer ce
serait plutôt sympa
il ya un truc qui m'a vachement bien ici
c'est les haut parleurs ça vraiment pas
mal nous ont mis des haut parleurs
stéréo
ça rajoute vraiment l'expérience
d'immersion ce qui fait que lorsque vous
voulez comme ça notre par ailleurs il
est là le deuxième et son côté 11
loutraki si on va avoir un déséquilibre
on n'est pas dans la meilleure
expérience audio on n'est pas sûr du
million on n'est pas sûr du million
ultra et compagnies non on est ici sur
du ray
notes 10 réduit nos dix pros mais malgré
tout l'expérience stéréo et là ça vient
spatialisé un peu plus sur ce que vous
venez jouer à des jeux c'est beaucoup
mieux pour le contenu multimédia alors
effectivement est ce qui est sympa dans
cette gamme de prix c'est qu'on va
continuer à trouver des prises jack ça
je voulais montrer ici vous avez une
prise jack 3.5 peut donc venir branche
est bien évidemment un casque sans aucun
problème sur leur éminente disent vous
avez du bluetooth 5.0 parce que son
modèle professionnel vous avez des
doutes ou cinq points voit une petite
différence de techno autre différence
qui est intéressant ce que je vous ai
pas mentionnée au niveau de l'écran
entre le modèle pro et leurs ennemis
note 10 un petit peu poule standard
c'est que son arrêt minute 10 pro vous
avez du hdr 10 vous avez des couleurs 8
bits donc on va aller plus loin au
niveau de l'expérience de visionnage
pour me regarder des films des séries
des jeux ce que vous voulez le meilleur
écran sera le modèle professionnel ya
une différence là dessus qui est
vraiment venu on paierait xiaomi ok
pourquoi pas mais je dirais que la
différence majeure est significatif
c'est qu'on va vraiment venir chercher
c'est celle au niveau de la photo alors
gardez vous le voyez ici vous avez un
grand temps qui est planqué justice''
capteur grand temps que c'est votre
caméra principale blessure 1,48
mégapixels tandis que sur l'autre modèle
vous avez ici un sens 8 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 1.9 avec la technologie 9
pixels en un qui apportera plus de
luminosité à vos photos et notamment
conditions de faible luminosité pour les
photos ni aurez compris un peu
l'histoire mais par contre si non c'est
exactement la même chose pour le reste
en dessous là c'est un ultra grand angle
ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels couvre
f 2.2 vous avez ici sur la gauche de la
macro caméra 2 mégapixels tout vrai que
2.4 et l'autre côté ici c'est une caméra
de 2 mégapixels couvre également f 2.4
ici il a pour le mode portrait pour les
facebook et donc au niveau de la photo
c'est sensiblement la même chose
lorsqu'il ya une petite différence
également au niveau de la caméra de
salfit honorer mes notes 10 et une 13
mégapixels kovalev 2.45 tandis que soit
le modèle professionnel en plein vient
sinon il a pas on est sur une 16
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.45 dans les
deux cas on peut bien filmé en 4k 30
images par seconde
bon ici la vidéo à venir oublié on va
pas les regarder c'est vraiment pas un
truc qui va venir m'intéressait parce
que on n'est pas sur des smartphones qui
sont optimisés pour faire de la vidéo
non on est sur les smartphones qui sont
vraiment optimisé pour faire de la photo
est encore optimisé je suis millions y
en a un des deux qui est mieux s'en sort
plutôt bien sur la partie gauche
ici on va voir leurs ennemis notre 10 et
sur la partie droite c'est le renmin dix
pros ce qu'on voit tout de suite ce qui
est très très clair c'est que on va
aller plus loin voire d'une meilleure
photo et de meilleures couleurs plus
saturées avec leurs amis à 10 pro
regarder
des tags ne serait ce que sur la
mauricie sur la partie de gauche là et
bien vous êtes chose qui est un peu
moins saturé un peu plus plat tandis que
d'autres cotonou un peu plus de relief
un peu plus de couleurs les contrats
sont aussi beaucoup plus soutenu on le
voyait au niveau de la couleur si vous
regardez le jeune au centre avec le
rouge à côté
eh bien voyez c'est plus saturés même
sur les violettes ici que l'autre côté
ça l'est beaucoup moins en effectivement
grosse différence de capteurs et on le
voit derrière au niveau du du ciel voyez
que les nuages avec leurs mélodies
surtout si tu as est cramé tandis que de
l'autre côté on a les détails on les
voit bien donc une vraie différence au
niveau de ces capteurs c'est clair c'est
très très clair et lorsque vous venez
zoomer dans vous repartez sur votre
capteur principal votre 48 mégapixels
sur le réduit de 10 et le sang 8
mégapixels ce au gremio 10 pro est une
fois de plus on le voit on va voir des
meilleures couleurs au niveau du modèle
professionnel que le couteau dont il est
beaucoup moins qu'on voit par contre des
deux côtés c'est que l'algorithme vient
vraiment compensé et je trouve pas ça
terrible terrible en x 2 alors je peux
monter jusqu'aux os x 10 d'un côté
l'autre je reste sur mon capteur
principal mais cette fois ci que vous
soyez sur leurs méthodes 10 ou sur l'eau
des professionnels dans les deux cas
c'est vraiment invivable c'est pas
terrible
là le ciel ça fonctionne bien d'un côté
et de l'autre pour voir qu'on
effectivement sur les deux modèles
différents bon une fois de plus était
ultra grand-angle c'est la même chose ou
yazoo mais on va conduire à des créneaux
qui sont quand même meilleur sans votre
ennemi no10 procure votre ennemi de
disent la même chose ici meilleures
photos sur le modèle professionnel il
faut vraiment faire attention passé du
temps dessus mais notés sur leurs
méthodes disent c'est pas mauvais je
crois que c'est mauvais mais je préfère
quand même leur ai mis nos dix pros et
vous le voyez au niveau de l'arbre la
voyez c'est un poil moins saturé là
c'est mieux saturé c'est mieux défini
c'est pas non plus extraordinaire mais
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux la même
chose ici on part que les nuages sont
cramés au niveau du modèle standard d'un
côté pas du tout une meilleure gestion
au niveau de la plage dynamique on
continue ici ça c'est flagrant pour moi
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus clair
beaucoup plus sympas ici de mêlée vos de
la couleur de l'image sur le modèle
professionnel que sans l'autre je
connais ma sud beaucoup plus plate moins
bien défini regardez le toit et son
espèce de grille là c'est un peu plus
complexe on a un gris un peu bleuté
c'est beaucoup plus joli
donc là c'est plus plat là il ya plus de
relief et je veux lui faire des photos
en faible luminosité est bien le modèle
professionnel s'en sortira mieux
j'ai pas dire que c'est extraordinaire
c'est pas extraordinaire mais se sentira
mieux tandis que sont leurs ennemis de
10 à l'orne à des aberrations tous les
côtés il a beaucoup plus de mal
beaucoup plus de mal à gérer toute cette
la luminosité à venir compenser le même
portrait feu un peu près l'hta fin ce
pas dingue dingue on en voit qu'au
niveau des cheveux c'est extrêmement
poussif détourage il n'est pas dingue
dingue il ya un petit peu de mal de
l'autre côté une fois de plus c'est pas
surprenant au niveau du pouce là il a
complètement manger j'ai perdu un bout
de tout cela
tant pis pour moi on peut également
faire la macro s'en sort pas trop mal
faut vraiment venir le plaquer faut pas
que ça bouge c'est pas fan de la macro
j'ai déjà dit plein de fois si on
souhaite le faire on peut le faire note
sur dumas n'a pas trouvé la bonne
distance
mais une fois qu'on a la bonne distance
et qu'on ait la bonne lumière dont vous
voyez truc un petit peu marre on
pourrait dire afficher sur l'écran
d'ordinateur donc voilà l'idée pourquoi
pas deux smartphones qui sont certifiés
ip à 53,1 garder en plus que vous avez
qu'elle fasse un pas vous avez double
nano signe + carte microsd donc ça c'est
plutôt bien pour venir augmenter votre
stockage sont venir choisir d'enlever
une des deux cartes sim donc si vous
êtes frontaliers que vous voyagez
beaucoup commencent un peu compliqué
mais ça va revenir et bien en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ici ce
smartphone là pourrait vraiment faire la
faire moi ces smartphones je les aime
bien je les aime bien pourquoi parceque
ils sont vraiment intéressants dans leur
segment de prix lancé évident qu'avec
par le renminbi c'est bien on fera moins
de choses qu'avec le modèle
professionnel le rémi de distiller il
est pas trop mal si on veut un
smartphone de shiomi son voeu
l'expérience soumis à moins de 200 euros
les photos seront de moins bonne qualité
on a vu que sont un poil plus ternes
donc moi je trouve ça c'est un petit peu
moins bien ça ça me donne moins envie
si on veut une belle dalle amoled pour
regarder des films des séries avec les
haut-parleurs stéréo
si on avait des choses qui est plutôt
correct et bien haut niveau l'expérience
leurs amis de 10 est intéressant mais
pour moi est celui qui va être le plus
intéressant c'est le modèle pro non pas
parce qu'il est plus cher non pas parce
qu'il écrit professionnelle mais parce
que les couleurs au niveau des photos
sur la caméra principale
je trouve beaucoup mieux je trouve plus
lumineuse j'ai trouvé plus joli plus
saturés plus clair ça c'est beaucoup
plus agréable
la macro de mode portrait passage le
mâconnais ça m'intéresse pas trop l'
ultra grand-angle un peu on peut mais
bon une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone à 250 euros à quelque chose
près donc bon voilà à faire non plus des
merveilles c'est des smartphones que
vous conservez quand même entre une
journée une
amy deux jours alors si vous jouez
beaucoup se fait tourner tous les jeux
vous râlez des films et vous fait
plaisir toute la journée que deux jours
on les aura pas mais si vous êtes un
poil plus mollo et bien vous les aurez
côté moi ce que j'aime bien ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est qu'il ya eu un
vrai beau travail de fait au niveau du
design là-dessus j'aime bien comment
sont venus intégrer leur module photo ça
c'est super original alors bon qu'on
vous enlever un petit peu la poussière
comme ça bien évidemment le fait d'avoir
ce petit décoché que vous retrouvez ici
la voiture volée le professionnel vous
avez comme une espèce de double marche
c'est pas mal qu'elle vous remarquez si
premium ultra bon c'est des trucs un peu
marketing c'est pour faire vendre
mais j'aime bien parce que vous avez un
smartphone qui coûte quand même pas trop
trop trop trop cher alors ça reste un
budget je suis d'accord mais on est
entre 200 à 250 euros et pourtant vous
avez un smartphone qui a vraiment de la
gueule
donc ça c'est chouette donc si vous
voulez un smartphone sympa polyvalent
qui en fera mais pas trop rubino dit si
vous voulez un poil plus loin meilleur
écran un poil plus de performances et
puis surtout des photos qui seront
meilleure qualité sur votre capteur
principal grâce à votre capteur de 8
mégapixels réduit notre 10 pro voilà
voilà j'essaie pour situer le tout ça
j'espère que ça vous aura aidé à mettre
à dégrossir un peu l'histoire
moi j'aime bien a vous de me dire
maintenant vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire comment vous les
trouvez ces smartphones est-ce qu'il
vous plaise qu'il pourrait vous tentez
savez c'est toujours un peu l'idée du
bon rapport qualité prix chez xiaomi
avec ses produits aux alentours de 200
250 euros quand on se retrouve très vite
vous des bisous des coeurs et puis si ça
va continuer à évoluer valeur d'autres
lumières j'ai essayé de changer des
choses voilà en fonction que vous allez
me dire bien évidemment toujours en bas
en commentaire à bientôt pour les soins
de ville j'en passe ciao